hi there what you're seeing here are
predictions by world model learned for
atari reinforcement learning
on the top you see what really happened
during an episode of play
and on the bottom you see the
predictions of this world model
the world model just gets five frames at
the beginning which
you don't even see here as a
conditioning and then it predicts 45
frames of gameplay
it's astounding how accurate it is not
only in terms of
how the game evolves but also in terms
of what the
agent will actually do so the world
model
the specific world model you see here is
part of the
dreamer v2 algorithm from the paper
mastering atari with discrete world
models
by dhoni jar hoffner timothy lilly krupp
muammat
naruzi and jimmy bah of google brain
deepmind
and the university of toronto so these
kind of world models they enable you
to do very quick reinforcement
learning once you have the model you can
use it to imagine
yourself playing the game instead of
actually playing the game
and therefore you can do much more
efficient reinforcement
learning and this paper details how to
get an accurate world model for atari
which
was sort of out of reach until now
especially
considering that they only do single gpu
reinforcement learning so the result as
you can see
here is going to be an algorithm that
is the top single gpu agent right now
competing you know outperforming other
so here is dreamer v2 out performing
other algorithms
such as rainbow iqn and dqn and the
special thing here
is that dreamer v2 is a model-based
algorithm
whereas the current or the previous
best ones especially single gpu best
ones
were model free algorithms and you can
see the next best
model based algorithms were are
not really competitive in atari right
this is specifically atari
so dreamer v2 is an evolution of dreamer
v1
which worked well for things like
continuous control
but atari still seemed a bit out of
reach so the difference between model
based reinforcement learning and model 3
reinforcement learning is that
model based reinforcement learning first
learns a world
model of the world it learns how the
world acts and then it uses that model
to learn what actions to perform whereas
model 3 algorithms they simply act in
the world
and they learn to predict the best
actions as they
act in the world so there's your
difference
and how does dreamer v2 do that on the
high level
it has two stages stage one
is learn a world model from past
experience
and then stage two is
use that world model as we said for
reinforcement learning and the
reinforcement learning here is going to
be just
actor critic learning um very
straightforward
uh there's a little modification with a
pass-through estimator
but the real difference is going to be
in how the world model
is learned and the novel contribution or
the main contribution here
is this latent state which
consists of a this stochastic latent
state which
other than other world models which
model the latent states as
something like gaussian random variables
uh
this paper models the latent state as
categorical
random variables and that turns out to
work pretty well
for atari so
that's step one learn world model step
two do a reinforcement learning
in the model so not using any data
anymore
and you can repeat those two steps as
many times as you want so you start out
with a
you know a set of data then you learn an
actor
and then you use that actor to collect
more data
and so on until you have a really good
actor and the world model is really
accurate for
that actor so that's the overview
and you know it's going to turn out as
we already saw
to to beat other at least single gpu
models by quite
a bit so we'll go through the paper
through the individual steps
and discuss what's new and how it all
works the code is also available i'll
link to it and the blog post i've shown
you here has
some more explanatory graphics if you
like content like this
as always don't hesitate to click like
and share it with all your friends
especially the atari gamers
because they are outperformed as you can
see here
alright so world models
uh pretty quickly in reinforcement
learning you
as you all hopefully or maybe know
you have an agent that is interacting
with an
environment and the agent
can so the environment always provides
the agent with an observation
oh here which would be an image in an
atari game
and the agent decides to do one of many
available
actions in response to receiving the
observation
the environment then responds with a
reward
for that action so either you die which
is like negative
reward or you collect a coin which is
positive reward or you win the game
which is like a thousand reward
and it also gives the agent a new
observation the next observation
and the agent again responds by
performing another
action and so on so you have this cycle
and the goal of a reinforcement learning
agent is usually to maximize
all the rewards that it collects during
playing with the environment and you
want to repeat that many times for many
episodes
to have the agent learn to get as
to do the actions that are as good as
possible in terms of reward
all right now in classic let's say
classic in model-free reinforcement
learning
one way to do this is to
take this right here as you play the
game
as you play the game you collect data
right so let's assume
we collect data as we act in the world
and
from this data we can we can learn
something
so model 3 learns from the raw
experience
so an episode will always be a series of
images
right and actions you have performed so
here is an image and i have performed
action one and then
came a next image and i've performed
action two so
what classic reinforcement learning
would do is it would say
okay from this transition doing this
action
i have gotten five um
five reward and from this
transition in this action i've gotten
negative three reward
so i'm going to have to do
this action one more often because it
gave me
a lot of reward after i observe this
thing
here right the combination of this thing
i need to do action one more
and when i'm in this situation i need to
do action to
less and so on okay
so you're simply trying to put this
image
that you get into a neural network that
tries to predict
action one as often as possible and you
want the same network
when you input this next image to
not predict action two so what anything
but action two
okay so that's going to be that's kind
of the logic between
uh of the classic model-free
reinforcement learning usually this is
implemented in a sort of an lstm
fashion or it's one way of doing it so
you have an lstm
that tracks a hidden state why do you
need a hidden state because you might
not see everything
in the image there is right this is not
necessarily markovian
so there might be information that you
need to remember for a long time like
when an enemy leaves the screen
and then comes back you want to track it
do you have an lstm or
some kind of rnn and then you want to
feed
the images into that one by one
and then you simply so with an encoder
which is usually kind of a convolutional
neural network
i'm going to draw it like this and then
you
try to predict the here the good actions
and here you try to not predict the bad
action
and so on so this is a simple classifier
ultimately it's an lstm
with a classifier on top and
the classifier simply tries to either
predict a
class of action one or not or predict
anything else right
so and you train it via back propagation
through
time and that's it
now here is a little bit different okay
so why why
is this maybe not a good idea
well all you have is the signal of the
reward
for given actions and that means
it is it is fairly hard to generalize in
these kinds of things
so when you imagine you have your screen
right here and you know there's an
opponent
kind of here there's an opponent here
and you are down here and the opponent
shoots right you have to move out of the
way you have to move
over here now rl is completely
capable of learning that however take
the next situation
over here now the opponent is here
shoots and you are down here
you have to again learn to move out of
the way
for a classic rl algorithm these two
things are ident
are completely different states like
this this is there's
nothing equal about the two like this is
a completely different thing
and it has to sort of learn by force
look
in this situation there you know you
need to move and in this situation you
also need to move now given that that is
a convolutional neural network it might
after a while
learn the fact that it you know these
two situations have something in common
but in essence these are two different
things and
you have to learn purely from the reward
purely from the fact that you're going
to die if you don't move
uh to get out of the way in two
situations
and of course this situation can be
replicated all over however if you have
a world model
right imagine now we have a world model
over here
and the world model accurately learns to
predict the future
now we know that you know we are here
this is here
now we can imagine ourselves forward
and we we're going to see we're going to
get hit
and that means we need to go out of the
way so
doing this explicitly would be called
planning
we are not going to do planning in this
paper okay
we are still going to do the classic rl
um
but you can see what advantages and a
world model
could do now the advantage of the world
model we have in this paper is
that it is going to enable this
left-hand process
much faster because we don't even we
don't need to interact with the world
anymore to learn all of this stuff
we can simply do this in imagination
while dreaming so to say that's why it's
called dreamer
and um learn the stuff on the left so
it's not
that the world model is used for
explicit planning for explicit thinking
ahead
it's just going to rapidly speed up this
process
on the left it's technically model-free
reinforcement learning
in a learned model which is i guess why
it's called model based
okay so how do we learn the world model
this is
quite a complex thing so the backbone as
you can see
is this h chain right here so the h
chain that is your classic keep where
the model
keeps track of a latent state so you
everything that's kind of going on
in the game right now you want
to save into the latent state so the
model is going to learn
a latent state transition and this
specifically is using a a
gru a recurrent neural network with a
gated recurrent unit so it's not an lstm
but it's kind of a the little brother of
the
lstm that is sometimes a bit easier to
train uh sorry
jurgen but this is the backbone okay
so from step to step we somehow we get
an observation
and we somehow want to incorporate that
information
and keep track of it now how how we do
it
usually this is it right usually you
just feed this into an encoder which in
this case is going to be a convolutional
neural network and then you combine that
you put that as an input into your
recurrent
cell let's disregard everything else for
a moment
how do you actually train the thing
usually in model 3 reinforcement
learning you would simply predict
the reward or the action that maximizes
the reward like you would predict
the best action to do in actor critic or
you can actually predict the q
value and q learning
not in model based we're trying to learn
a model so
what we're going to do is we're going to
try to predict
here the we're going to try to predict
the image now this can be
in fact the next image or it can be the
same image and i don't even
remember which one it is um
okay it predicts
i don't know so it can i'm going to
guess it
i'm going to guess it reconstructs the
same image
okay so here you can see
the image predictor oh yeah so xt
is predicted from ht and zt
so we want to reconstruct the same image
first and foremost okay so we input an
image and we want to get out the same
image this is like an like an auto
encoder okay
so the representation we're going to get
in the middle here
somehow needs to uh be able to represent
the image very well and we also want to
predict
the reward um here we're also going to
get an
action it's you can see it here more so
we're going to
get an action remember we are learning
from experience
we have done this here a bunch of times
and we have a data set
of experience so we know what actions we
took
we're going to learn a model that tells
us given we're in this state and perform
a
certain action what's going to happen so
we're going to learn
the reward and the image
okay and it might not make too much
sense
with the same frame but if you look at
the next frame
it makes a bit more sense so given image
x1
we want to encode it somehow right and
then
through the gru over here we
are informed well while after x1
happened we did in this episode we did
a1 and then we got reward
r2 and the resulting image
was x2 okay so
we're trying to predict given an
observation and a latent state
this h1 we're trying end in action we're
trying to predict
what reward we got and what the game
looked like after we performed the
action
this is trained in back propagation
through time
so not only do we predict you know one
future image but we actually predict a
sequence of rewards
and images okay so that's how we're
going to
learn a world model input observations
and actions and
output rewards and observations
okay and that's exactly what you saw at
the beginning in these videos
so they the model was simply input a
bunch of frames here
and then rolled out for a number of
steps and it
you know we looked at the output of this
this is by the way this is a
deconvolutional
neural network like a deconvolutional
you know like in a dc
gan um type of type of network
okay now what are these special parts
right here
um these special parts are what makes
this
model work so the hidden state as you
can see the thing i circled in red in
the middle
is not just the recurrent neural network
hidden state
it is actually a combination of two
things
they call this a combination of a
fixed state of a um deterministic state
and a stochastic state so
what you're going to have is you're
going to have
the state which is a vector
this is the h let's call that h0 okay
of the of the lstm
now you're going to get an action into
this as we saw before
the action is combined with this
and you ask yourself given that action
and the hidden state
and now we don't just want to know
what's the
next hidden state like in a normal rnn
what we're going to predict is actually
this z
variable right here and this z variable
is a description of the current state a
stochastic description of the current
state
in a very specific form so the h is
simply a vector right you can store in
it whatever you want
but the z which is going to be
concatenated to the h
it's going to be both is going to be
predicted from the
h and it is also going to be
concatenated
to the h for further processing so
you're going to predict
this thing together with the
image x down here you're going to
predict
that z thing and you're also going to
concatenate it to h for further
processing so the red circle is going to
be the
concatenation and not even that okay
maybe i should explain what it is
so it is going to be of this form it is
going to be
a collection of categorical variables
each having you know 32
so it's 32 categorical variables
each having 32 possible classes and the
model can decide
absolutely by itself what the
categorical variables are for
and what each of the classes mean so
for example in the space invaders game
right
one categorical could be the location
of the agent location right
and the 32 different values it could
take
or maybe going to be you know if this
value
is if it's this value then it means
the agent is somewhere down here in this
quadrant or
in this tile if it's this value right
here
the agent is going to be in here and so
on
so these are categorical values and
it they can you know take one of these
different values they can only take one
so that's the difference between these
and like a a gaussian
latent variable because these stochastic
states used to be modeled
in like say you know we have 32
gaussians like in a
in a vae we have 32 of these latent
variables
now we make them categorical and that
turns out to be pretty good
for this atari games so the other could
be
the enem does the enemy shoot
is you know has the enemy fired a shot
now maybe we don't
need 32 variables right here like this
could simply mean
this could simply mean yes and this
could simply mean no but also you know
we can make use we can encode actually
16 different enemies
so we can encode has this enemy shot
that we see here
or has an enemy that is potentially here
fired a shot or has an enemy that is
potentially here
fired a shot right we can we can encode
this in that now i can see that
you can see the problem right two
enemies can
shoot at the same time and in a
categorical variable you can only have
one value
however it might still be enough to just
encode you know whichever enemy has
shot most recently or least recently
into this variable
and you can still play the game with
that information
okay so you can see here
that so it's 32 variables so 32 we can
have 32 here and each can have
32 different values and you know the
estate is going to be described by
um
by having each of these 32 variables
be you know in one position or another
as you can see
right here and
hey it's yannick from the future um
i forgot the whole video to show you
this
so i'm doing it now they have a pretty
good explanation of
why categorical variables might be
important for a thing like
atari and that is because sometimes you
have
pretty big junctures in the world state
so
maybe you know you do very similar
actions or maybe slightly different
actions from the same states
but you know the slightly different
action results in different changes in
the world
and that means your your prediction sort
of has to capture all of that so
when your predictions is just a gaussian
a gaussian
can only sort of have a mean and a
variance it cannot
predict multi-modal distributions
however
a categorical distribution can like it
can be spiky it can be very concentrated
on one particular thing or it can
actually be a superposition of many
different states and when you sample
from that you actually have your
multi modality so it's again something
that is
kind of very suited to certain
environments but not others
and you know when it fits then
um it seems to work pretty well but this
is in the blog post
if you want to look at this graphic
yourself all right back to past yannick
bye-bye you can see that the entire
observation sequence the observations
they
never get into the system except through
these z variables so this is an extreme
compression
every observation that you get in is
going to be described
by this extremely compressed format
and they hypothesize that you know
because it's so compressed because it's
so sparse
it might actually force the model to
learn pretty good
latent variables and that's also why
it's so fast
because you never touch the
observations again you only work in this
latent space
so what actually happens is the cnn is
going to predict
a distribution so for each of the 32
variables
is going to predict a distribution
of the 32 values that variable could
take
and one here and one and so on
okay it's going to predict 32
distributions of that
and then there is a sampling step so
this is now sampled from
this is the sign for sampling from and
that gives you
not 32 distributions but it actually
gives you
32 just straight okay here
here here okay so
this is why it's called the stochastic
part so
in that i'll actually make that blue
so you realize that is going to be fed
here
so this this deterministic state h is
going to be
used to predict this distribution
the distribution is going to be sampled
from and then this
sample is going to be concatenated
together with h
and that will finally make our actual
latent state so the latent state here is
this concatenation
out of the deterministic and out of a
sample
of the stochastic and that ensures
that you sort of keep your your options
because it's sampled about the world
model you always
draw from this distribution which you
can entropy regularize
right but you also have the
deterministic information that you pull
through okay so that's how the hidden
state
comes to be and there is one node we
haven't left out right yet
okay during learning during actual
reinforcement learning what you want to
do
is the following you simply want to
start off
with a single observation or actually a
hidden state that you've seen during
training of the world model and
from that point on you don't want to
have anything to do with observation so
you see right here
since we pre we learned a reward
predictor
right we can simply use that reward
instead of the real environment so
and we don't want observations anymore
so what you want to do is you simply
want to
use this backbone here to predict
the these latent states so you simply
want to unroll these latent states
now usually in order to do that you need
the observation you can see here clearly
the next latent state is a result of the
previous one
and the action and the observation
now if you don't want to do this it
means you have to
predict the observation but you can't
predict the observation because that
would be
slow and we already know that doesn't
really work so you want to predict
this z variable we've said that
observation the next observation
is going to be fed into the algorithm
through this
by means of constructing such a z
variable so
if you could predict that variable
without seeing the observation you could
you don't need the observation anymore
and that's exactly the last output right
here you can see
each h state no is not only used to
construct that z
variable together with the observation
we also
predict the same z variable but without
looking at the observation okay of
course that's going to be not as good
like the latent representation is going
to be much better when you actually see
what happens in the game
however in order to do dream
reinforcement learning we
need to be able to completely detach
from the observations
and that's why we also predict at the
same time
we predict the same variable but without
seeing the observation
and then we're going to introduce a loss
function
that makes it such that these two
are going to be very close together so
the agent now has to do a trade-off and
the trade-off is
do i want to get the best information
out of my observation
do i want to represent it as accurately
as possible in order to
reconstruct it really well and in order
to predict the reward really well
or do i want to be able
to predict this thing
without seeing the observation which
means that you know i have to
i have to not rely as much on the image
i have to rely more
on learning the actual dynamics of the
world and what happens when i perform
actions in them
that's what exactly what this kl
divergence here is going to do
so the model has to find a trade-off
between the two
and if you engineer that trade-off
correctly
you are able to use the just the
predicted z
variables instead of the true ones at
least for a certain number of steps i
think they do 15 steps into the future
during learning
and of course the errors accumulate
because you never able to predict that z
exactly however it's enough
to do good reinforcement learning and
this sparsity here
it helps very much okay i know this is a
lot
but you know to shortly recap learning a
world model means that you input
observations
and you learn to predict the future so
you learn to predict the future
observations
you learn to predict the future rewards
given
actions given actions that you performed
you start off with a random agent or any
agent you want you simply want to learn
what happens when i do something now
the way you predict that is going to be
through a recurrent neural network
the latent state of which is going to be
a combination of a classic latent state
of an
rnn and concatenated
with a sample from a stochastic
very very compressed state that you
obtain from a cnn encoder
combined with the last hidden state
okay so the combination of a sample from
this and the deterministic state is
going to be
your compact world model state from
which you predict the future
and in addition to that you also try to
predict
this stochastic state just from
the deterministic hidden state and the
action
without knowing what the actual next
observation is
or the current observation i guess and
that means you can then use those
prediction values
at reinforcement learning time in order
to
be completely decoupled from the
observations
and now yeah we we sort of have it
so what if you learn a world model like
this what you can do now is you
don't need the observations anymore you
maybe need one
start observation and you simply unroll
into the future
and you do reinforcement learning in
this completely
imaginary like this is a dream now this
is
oh dream um this is
just dream a dream now
it's uh it's uh also completely
not cheated um
yeah so the reinforcement learning they
do right here
is going to be something like you know
a2c
or a3c it's going to be an actor critic
uh
method an advantage actor critic method
that's a pretty
basic uh but very strong reinforcement
learning algorithm
where you learn sort of two models you
learn the critic
that accumulates that tries to predict
the future
rewards so it tries to predict these
values right here
and you learn an actor that is trying to
make the critic
really really happy now
um you swap this once you have a good
agent you go back you collect more data
because your world model is never going
to be accurate
it's never going to replace actually
playing the environment
your world model only has data from
where the agent
goes right that's where it learns from
so it's crucial
that once you have a better agent you
update your world model because now the
agent does different things
and it goes places that the world model
has never seen
right if you know if you have this um
if you have like a maze game okay
and the maze is i don't know i'm not
good at mazes but
you know you're here and once you crash
into a wall
you're done so the agent it will just be
random at the beginning so it'll like
crash a lot into these walls and so on
just do random actions
so the world model if it just learns
from that experience
it is going to learn maybe that there's
a wall right here
but this thing we don't know right now
if you get a little bit of reward maybe
there's a coin right here
okay and every now and then this stupid
random agent
actually finds the coin right it walks
over here and finds the coin gets a
reward
the reinforcement learning means that
it's going to do that more often so
now the agent is going to walk over here
more and more often but you only do that
in the world model the world model only
knows up until here because that's where
the agent has gone
the farthest now that the agent goes
further right
you actually need to go back to the
environment
and let the agent run in the true
environment because now
that agent's going here you know it's
going to explore a bit more
um because you know it it learned
it learned only seeing this and now it
learns a bit more you record
you build out your world model it's like
ah there's the wall goes until here but
then there's a free space and then
maybe something comes here and so on so
working with world model is not is not
super easy
and it only is going to
this is very specific and this is going
to be my my criticism
right here in that all of this seems
quite specific to atari now
reinforcement learning is such a big
field and such a general algorithm that
you're going to
build in some kind of prior knowledge
about the world
but it seems like the some reinforcement
learning papers i never know
you know how much is this all applicable
to
other rl environments it seems like this
you know is specifically for
atari and learning these world models in
this fashion is only going to work
if you know every now and then you find
a reward you still have the explore
exploit dilemma if your world model
isn't accurate then you know you're not
going to do accurate rl
and so on and maybe the density of
rewards isn't going to be enough
for you to actively push yourself up in
these cycles
and you know there's another problem
with these latent variables they're
categorical which i think you know is
super cool because it gives you a sparse
representation
but you only learn it from
the images in fact they say they can
even leave away the reward predictor for
the world model so you
learn to reconstruct the images
however if two images are very close to
each other
but they mean different things in the
game so you know
two images can be super duper close like
an enemy can be here
or slightly off right but if it's
slightly off it doesn't hit you
and therefore you know you're all good
now these two states are still pretty
close because
if you move a bit you're likely to get
hit but sometimes
a little bit of a change in image can
mean actually a big
change in game state
and vice versa which is actually even
worse a big
change in image can mean like it doesn't
matter like if
everything in the image rotates around
but your agent
still has nothing and is at the same
place
it means nothing to you as a human yet
an algorithm like this
that whose goal it is to predict
the future as accurately as possible it
will devote a lot of attention
to accurately predict the future
or predict variances in the future
even though they might not be relevant
so
in this in this task of or in this
bottleneck of encoding everything into a
very compact state
you might actually lose important
information and that means
all of all of the like two states that
are very
very far like need to be differentiated
are going to be just
the same in this representation and
there that means your agent
will will never really learn because one
is bad and one is good so the mean
reward is
zero and it says well when i get to that
state
my mean reward is kind of zero and it's
just kind of a big variance
and then the world model will never
learn the difference
because it has bigger things to worry
about so this is
it's all very specific and you'll see
this
in the in the lost term right here so
this is the
loss function for learning the world
model and you can see they have an image
reconstruction loss right here this is a
this is a cross-entropy loss so it's um
this is your approximation distribution
this is what really
happened um um yeah it's a
it's kind of a probabilistic way of of
writing things so these are
cross-entropy losses when you see log p
of the expectation of under q um
they have a loss predicting the reward
they have a loss predicting the discount
which is you know mainly made for
predicting when an episode ends in the
in the imagine trajectory
and then they have this transition loss
coupled with the entropy
regularizer so the transition loss is
going to be for predicting these
uh z states um and the entropy
regularizer
is for keeping the distribution in the z
states not peaked uh so you
want to kind of retain that
stochasticity and this together you
might recognize as the
kl divergence between the
p and q and that's this connection right
here
so i'm going to minimize the k
l which is the same as saying i want
this thing to be as accurate
uh sorry i won't i want i want these
things to be as close as possible to
each other
but the entropy should um should still
be given
and yeah as you can see here you can you
can you can decompose that
so this is going to be this is going to
be the the kl divergence between the two
distributions
i don't have a better way of explaining
that without writing it down
um you can already see
they have a massive amount of hyper
parameters right
like here's one here's one here's one
here's one here's one
okay uh so even within the kl divergence
they have actually two one hyper
parameter for the kl diversion and one
to trade off
the entropy with the actual cross with
the
transition log loss with the cross
entropy there
and they do ablations and see that that
is really important that you have that
trade-off that you're able to make that
trade-off and
it's the same as the as the beta
variational auto encoder
by the way it's an entire paper about
why you need an additional hyper
parameter here
like that's the entire paper uh of bit
of eaes
which i found funny but you know it
seems to be important so you can see
right here
this is kl balancing so you
have one uh you have one term
for making the prior close to the
posterior the prior being the one
where you just see h and the posterior
being the one where you
see h and x
and you have another term for making the
posterior close to the prior and you
trade them off
with these variables right here
then the reinforcement learning itself
again has a bunch of hyper parameters so
it is doing td lambda learning and yeah
you can look that up td london learning
basically means you are here in your
state and
you're going to predict the value sorry
the reward
going to the next state and you're going
to predict the value at that state
and then you're also going to predict
from the same state the reward
two steps forward and the value at that
state and you're also going to predict
the reward three steps forward and
the value at that state and at the end
you're going to sum
all of that up into one number uh that
is kind of an
aggregate of all of this and that's
going to be your prediction that's what
you regress
on in your value predictor and the
yeah the actor tries to maximize that
so there's another parameter lambda
that tells you how you aggregate these
things right and
also h for how many steps you do that
um there's also going to be in the actor
loss function
they decided not only do they want the
classic reinforced
loss as you have you actually want the
a straight through estimator of
the distribution and so a straight
through estimator
is when you want to back prop through
sampled things
normally the reinforced gradients what
they do is if your actor outputs a
distribution let's say over three
actions
right you don't all you can say
is that i i did action two
here and it gave me seven reward
right so you wanna make that more likely
because seven is pretty good
actually you subtract the baseline but
you know let's say after the baseline
it's seven
so you simply act like
you have a target distribution of this
and scale it by seven that's reinforced
gradients
what you could also do is you could
actually regress
on directly through the soft max
operation
right here because this here
is a sampling step you cannot backprop
through sampling steps
the way you can do it is that you
you take the signal the loss signal here
but you act as if this was your output
and not this okay so you act as if you
had made actions in
proportion to their distribution
and not actually sampled one particular
action this is going to give you a
biased signal
but it has much lower variance whereas
if you sample
and then scale it's going to be unbiased
but much
higher variance so they do these
straight through estimators not only
here but actually also
in this step up here and you can see how
that works
in modern deep learning frameworks so
you have your distribution in terms of
your logits so what you can do is you
sample from them
and forward propagate should be the
sample
right so the trick is to do plus and
minus
the same thing so the forward
propagation signal is simply your sample
as you can see right here now the sample
this operation it has no gradient oh you
can't see that
it has no gradient so the deep learning
framework will simply not backprop
through it so if you were to just
use the sample in your graph you won't
get a gradient
but what you can do is you can actually
calculate the probabilities here like
the thing you want to back propagate
and then do plus that and minus stop
gradient of that
you can see right here this has no
gradient
this has no gradient so the gradient is
going to be
as if you had forward propagated this
probs
variable but on the forward pass
the probs variable exactly cancels out
with
itself and the sample is forward
propagated this is called a straight
through estimator gives you a bias
gradient
but much less variance than
if you had to you know if you scale the
sample like the reinforced gradients
so they use this in the world model and
they use this actually
in the actor loss right here and
you can see there is another
hyperparameter
here is another hyperparameter and then
they have an entropy regularizer to
facilitate exploration
which is normal but gives you another
regularizer and not only do they have
sorry a hyperparameter not only do they
have these three additional hyper
parameters
they scale two of them during training
so they now have a schedule to scale
them so they this
straight through estimator they actually
scale it to zero over the course of
training but yet
two more hyper parameters normally how
fast you want to decay
those things so this whole
thing is a giant bucket
of hyper parameters and
so they say
while the unbiased reinforced gradients
can help a better final solution however
we find that using only reinforced
gradients for optimizing the policy
also works well it might just not work
as fast
or as well but it also works well
but you know that in general this is
reinforcement learning but this
is a bit you know the amount of hyper
parameters here
is quite staggering and i'm going to
guess that
this took a lot of work to even get
off the ground right um so here you can
see
how this compares to other algorithms uh
specifically blue here is dreamer v2 and
they do suggest a bunch of different
things so they have
task media and gamer normalized so gamer
is
a professional human level gamer and
gamer normalized means you simply divide
by
what that professional gamer can do so
you can see that
it can even exceed you know this gamer
so here
is over 1.5 times over 55 different
atari games
very good however these atari games some
of them
are actually unbounded and in some of
them
a machine can just be so much better
than a human that usually these scores
are dominated by very very few
games where the machine just excels you
know
hugely and other games are like
zero and both the median score
and the mean score they are not really
meaningful at least that's what this
paper here argues
so they propose two modifications so the
first modification actually this is from
a different paper as well
says you shouldn't normalize by you know
kind of a professional gamer you should
actually normalize
by the human world record so this is
record normalized you can see it gives a
cleaner uh score and
then they say well given that a few
games
still the um the machine can just
outperform humans so much what you
should do
is actually you should never allow
so you just you should just clip
the machine score at where the human
world record is
so the reasoning behind this i can
imagine is something like
what's the difference between the human
world record and the professional gamer
world record well the human world record
the professional gamer is already pretty
good at
gaming in general let's say but the
human world record holder has probably
you know
figured out every single detail of that
particular game and this
you know is is pushing it with like
exploits and and whatnot you know i
don't know if you've seen
legend like ocarina of time speed runs
lately but they're crazy
um so that is going to be human world
record and it's probably going to be
better to normalize by this because you
know the machine
will necessarily find these kind of
exploits they will it will probably find
them as well however
there are some things that where the
machine you have to be where you have to
be like pixel
and microsecond accurate where the
machine can do it and the human can't
so clipping it might make sense
i'm not really sure about this like
there's arguments to be made that
you maybe shouldn't normalize by the
human world record because
you know you don't want to give credence
to like uh exploits
but the gamer kind of represents more
how the game is
intended to be played i don't know uh
they just suggest
this new score just so happens to be
that in this new score
they are you know other than here they
are just
dominating at all time points
yeah let's let's leave them that they do
a quite a number of ablations especially
they find out that
for example if they do latent variables
as categorical that outperforms gaussian
latent variables
by a lot so um and that's
you know that's kind of a reasoning why
they use the categorical variables
the kl balancing simply means that
additional parameter
in the kl term if they enable it you can
see
it helps a lot image gradients so when
they
they wonder can we learn the world
models from
predicting images or from predicting
rewards or from both
so they do both as a default
but if they leave away the image
gradients it doesn't work anymore
however if they leave away the reward
gradients you can see it still works
pretty well
again this is all quite atari specific
and it also means that
you can see right here right the atari
game
lends itself to this kind of to exactly
this kind of
model so how much this is a
success for general reinforcement
learning
uh is questionable however what you can
say is that if an environment
lends itself to be world
model learned by this kind of
latent categorical variables like so if
the image state
is going to be if changes in the image
are going to be a good indicator of
actual
changes in relevant world variables
then you know you might you might be
very suited with a model like this
and so they compare this to other
algorithms for example
uh to mu0 which doesn't run on a single
gpu i think it is better but it doesn't
run
on a single gpu uh and it uses kind of a
lot more atari
frames than uh the the dreamer algorithm
so you see again that uh you just need
to find the correct category and you can
be state of the art so if
this is like single gpu atari
no i don't wanna i don't wanna dunk on
this this is pretty cool work and
if you look at the code it took a lot of
effort like you can see that from the
code
okay the last thing i want to look at is
where does it succeed and where does it
fail so you can see it comparison for
example dreamer v2 versus iqn or dreamer
v2 vs
rainbow and you can see and
particularly interesting is where does
it fail
and it fails in video pinball and
actually i don't have it pulled up right
here
but if you look it up so
if you look it up you can probably see
why
because this video pinball thing
thanks thanks youtube
this video pinball thing it has a lot of
changes in image
without really doing much you know
changes
in the world state so what actually
matters is like
this little tiny ball this little tiny
you know it's kind of
a bunch of pixels and the rest you know
kind of
moves around and um okay maybe it
doesn't move too much
right here but still you know there's
this new cross that appears and so on
so a world model that learns
to you know there's kind of flashes over
the whole image
a world model that learns to accurately
predict the world
maybe is going to not focus so much on
that little ball
but maybe is going to focus more on the
rest of the image if that
changes well and also you can see maybe
the reward
now and again a flash the reward doesn't
change all too much
um
yeah it does maybe but you know any any
time
it bumps somewhere so my hypothesis is
going to be
that you know in games where what
actually matters
uh consists of very few changes in the
actual image and there are
lots of other big image changes that
don't really matter so much for the
immediate reward maybe for the future
but
for not for the immediate this algorithm
is going to
not be as good and that is one example
is this video
pinball and i might be wrong on this but
it's kind of a
hypothesis so the code for this is going
to
is available right here uh check it out
as well as you should check out the blog
post
they have a lot of ablations right here
as you can see and graphs for the
individual games turning off and on
different variables
and you might as well give it a try if
you have a reinforcement learning
problem that has an environment similar
to atari
alright that was everything i had to say
for this pretty cool paper check it out
bye